&gt;&gt; Well, the first equation is in slope intercept form. The slope is 4 and the
y-intercept is 7. This second one is a little bit tricky,. It is in slope
intercept form. I know the slope is 3 and the y-intercept is actually 0. If I
add a 0 in the end, I don't change the equation, so this is also in the correct
form. This third option is not in slope intercept form. It's actually in
standard form. It's a form we're going to learn about soon. We know it's not in
slope intercept form because we have a coefficient in front of the y. The y
should be sought for, or it should be alone on one side of the equals sign. This
equation is also in slope intercept form. The slope is 1 3rd. And the
y-intercept is negative 4. Even though our form has a plus sign in it, I know I
can rewrite subtraction as adding the opposite. So, this is definitely in slope
intercept form. This fifth option is not in slope intercept form. I have a
coefficient of 3 in front of the y, so the y isn't solved for. And finally, this
last equation is in slope intercept form. Because remember, even though we don't
write it, there's a 1 in front of a x. This is the coefficient, or the slope of
our equation. If you got at least half of these right, excellent work. You've
really got an understanding of slope intercept form.